foreign
I confided in a dear friend of mine
that my lifelong wish was to see the
blue whales
before I knew it I found myself with a
bunch of researchers in the sea of
Cortez studying the blue wedge
we used to be in a boat 25 foot long
and next to us
is this Majestic
creature
feeding gracefully next to us
now you have to understand at that point
in time I knew nothing about blue whales
or whales in general I'm just a
financial economist
but I learned something from them which
was really incredible
it was already known in the science
that Wales
capture so much carbon
on their body
and indirectly
and that's of course very important for
us because we're all fighting the
climate Calamity and we're all talking
about how to grab carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere
well it turns out that the whales
crack grab so much carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere by the way they eat
and they poop
yep it's all about poop
so how how does the whale system work
well start in the oceans
there's these microscopic organisms
called phytoplankton
those phytoplankton do something really
incredible
they grab so much carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere
and they return oxygen to all of us
now how much carbon dioxide do they grab
from the atmosphere
about 37 gigatons of carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere
truly the lungs of the planet are in the
ocean
now if you want to visualize what 37
gigatons mean
that's the equivalent of the carbon
that is grabbed by four Amazon forests
per year
that's how much is being sucked in by
the these photosynthetic organisms
now
larger creatures called Krill love to
eat phytoplankton dietically or
indirectly
and the whales love to feed on the krill
they feed so much on the Krill that they
grow bigger and bigger and they store
carbon in their body
how much carbon do they store in their
body
roughly about seven
to nine tons of carbon on their body
if you want to convert that to carbon
dioxide that's about 33 tons of carbon
dioxide being kept out of the atmosphere
on the body of a single whale
if you want to visualize that that's the
work of 1500 trees
on the body of a single wedge
okay
but those guys because they eat a lot
what do you do next you poop a lot
and their poop turns out to be
incredibly important because it
fertilizes the phyto
so you have this wonderful cycle
okay the whale feeds on the Krill the
Krill feeds on the phyto and the fighter
needs the poop of the whale to get more
active and when the fighter gets more
active it grabs more carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere
so just imagine
the whales
they capture Carbon on their body
unfortunately at some point they die and
they're so heavy they sink to the bottom
of the ocean
and anything below a thousand meters is
sequestered almost forever
and through their poop they also
fertilize fight or making fight to even
more active grabbing more carbon dioxide
on the atmosphere
so in a sense the whales are incredible
allies
in the fight against climate change
now that's good news right yeah
except that whales are dying
they're dying from ship strikes they're
dying from pollution then dying from
entanglements
in fact they're dying because our
current economic system
puts a zero value on the living waves
but Chopper whale sell it for its meat
it acquires a value
in fact the value of a living whale is
zero zero dollars zero in any currency
I'm a financial economist
and I'm listening to these scientists
bemoaning what's happening to the Wiz
and I wanted to help I didn't know how
to help and I thought wait a minute
maybe I can bring your message
to the to to the audiences around the
world maybe I can translate all of that
value those services that you do for us
in a language that we can all understand
unfortunately it's a language of dollars
and cents
so I set out with my team to to Value
the services of a whale but one service
because the way of Zoom
a whole host of things but I just wanted
to Value one thing which is what is the
value of their carbon sequestration
service to us now how would you do
something like that after all the whale
is a living system
the whale captures Carbon on her body
and she gives birth to baby whales who
also grow up to to capture Carbon on
their body and they give birth to to
whales and so forth and indirectly
through the fertilization of phyto so
how would you do something like this
well to do that I had to resort to my
what I do best which is valuation I
looked at it I said to us wait a minute
this looks like a share of stock that
pays dividends
except those Dividends are live
dividends they give birth to more
dividends
so if I were to track the whale over her
lifetime and keep keep track of all
these dividends into the future
and then multiply that by the price of
carbon
and discount that all the way to the
present
I can't figure out what is the present
value discounted present value of the
lifetime earnings of a single wear
would you like to know how much
would you like to know how much
at least three million dollars
at least
because I'm leaving so much out of this
but I just wanted to tell the good news
that I heard on that boat I didn't know
what to do I was trying to help them out
but there's more good news would you
like to hear it
their cousins on land the the elephants
in the forests of Africa
in the Congo Basin they do the same
thing
turns out the way they walk and they eat
and they poop
they increase carbon sequestration in
the trees in the forest between seven
percent and 14 percent
just imagine just by frolicking around
they're helping us to grab carbon from
the carbon dioxide from the atmosphere
and fix it
so I thought hey maybe maybe we can
value their services too
right
same thing it's just but again use the
same model of valuation you follow the
same methodology and you discount all of
that to the present and you ask yourself
what is the value of a single elephant's
carbon sequestration service
would you like to know how much
here we go
2.6 million dollars
would you like to hear some more good
news
aside from forests because we are land
people we just think of forests go a
little bit into the water
sea grass salt marsh
mangroves kelp forests beatland Wetland
these are living systems that suck in so
much carbon dioxide beyond your
imagination and they keep it forever in
their Roots as long as you leave them
alone and you look after them
so
if you think these numbers are big
wait till you see what I'm about to tell
you next
in seagrass alone
seagrass alone carbon sequestration
how much you think is the value of the
globe if you look at globally the sea
grass and you value their carbon
sequestration service
how much do you think it's worth
you ready
2.3 trillion dollars
that's the size of the German stock
market
now
what does this tell us
this tell us
that a living and thriving nature is not
only valuable intrinsically
it's also financially valuable to us
question is what do you do with this so
the science tells us how what a wondrous
Earth we are on
we can value it in dollars and cents
questions what are you going to do with
it well guess what we can build the
whole economy around a living and
thriving nature
not an extractive view of nature but a
regenerative view of nature
and that economy thank you
that economy is going to deliver for us
sustainable and shared prosperity for
all big and small all creatures on this
planet
it does not have to be I win you lose it
it is a win-win I'm going to show you
how
from there we can build in order to
build that economy we need three things
we need the science the accounting the
scientific account what is it that you
have
how much of it do you have
than people like me Financial economists
come around and they say what is the
value of what you have the reason we
value it is just to basically translate
it into the language that policy makers
can understand so they can make
decisions that's all it's a translation
but then the third pillar is very
important which is the legal framing the
legal framing is very important
because we need to protect the rights of
nature a living and thriving nature
three things once you do these three
things
you can create markets around nature
when I say markets around nature not an
extractive view of nature but a
regenerative view of Nature and I'm
going to show you how I'm going to show
you how
Gabon has 57 000 elephants
if you leave them alone they can grow to
195 000 elephants
Gabon can sell the carbon offsets
of its elephants imagine because those
elephants are grabbing carbon in the
trees
they can sell the carbon offsets of
their elephants
to whom
to us because we're all enamored with
going carbon zero carbon negative carbon
neutral
and our money will come in to look after
these elephants in perpetuity
okay
so how much revenue can Gabon get out of
it
one billion dollars a year
from allowing these elephants to frolic
freely not be tied to anything just by
leaving them alone those elephants by
the way they walk they poop just being
having babies doing whatever they do
they help carbon sequestration in the
forest a forest without animals is dead
it's not about Flora it's about flora
and fauna it's about nature itself
that's what the message is
who would buy
these carbon offsets all these companies
and countries that made commitments to
carbon zero carbon negative carbon
neutral
they would buy the carbon offsets or
carbon credits if you like the money
would flow in
from this ecosystem Services be it the
whales be the elephants be Mangrove
secret salt marsh and the money goes in
by contract
using blockchain technology to look
after nature and perpetuity
very important and to look after the
stewards of nature in perpetuity and the
stewards of nature are the local and the
indigenous population
they're the ones
who are doing the conservation not you
and me
once
we do that
notice what it is it's a win for nature
it's a win for the economy
the government will make money because
the government's going to get all that
Revenue it will change its fiscal stance
it will diversify its economy it will
grow in a sustainable way
it's a it's a win for the environment
it's a win for all these creatures that
have suffered so much at our hands
it's a win for this beautiful Earth of
ours
as Carl Sagan once said
the only Earth will ever know
the only home we'll ever know
it's a win for us
we're taking this work
in Africa to Liberia Cameroon Kenya
South Africa we're taking this work to
the Americas Chile Argentina we're doing
it in the U.S and in the UK
imagine it just started with just a wish
of mine
to see a blue wave
little did I know I'm going to it's
going to end up with a vision of how we
ought to live for tomorrow
thank you
[Applause]